there's so many profound songs on his
first album
um i think that uh
damien is one that always sticks out to
me as one of my favorites
that's one of the songs that he wrote in
north carolina with us in the house
and that's the one that's great you said
that in the world i'm saying who's
actually just discussing that
that's one of the fastest songs he wrote
he actually timed himself he said you
know what i'm gonna see how fast i could
write you know
yeah i just wrote a song before that
that's kind of fast
but it didn't have the hook he said you
know what i think i could write
even faster than that i mean cuz i think
i just knocked out a song for like two
and a half hours whole song boom
right so he tried to top that and he
topped it with damien he wrote damien in
an hour and a half
wow hook and everything that that whole
him playing two different people yeah
not me nah that's ex doing that and
he wrote both of those parts and uh
everything one i went 30 minutes
so you're you're in there while he's
writing this and and uh yeah
no but i'm curious because like
obviously him rapping from the
perspective of
the you know the devil or whatever you
want to call it damien you know yo d
what's up you a smooth so like
was like did he have the like like talk
about the concept like how did he come
up with that concept because if you guys
were there i mean that's crazy that's a
that's one of the crazier records on his
first album that like always just sticks
out to me
yeah yeah like that right there that was
something he was actually dealing with
in
life in reality you know i mean that
right there so that was real fam like
that was
i'm telling you that's the fastest
record if because it always felt to me
as a kid not knowing any better i always
thought to myself
damn dmx sold his soul to the devil
and then belly came out and in the
opening scene
there's a little boy and he's quoted
[ __ ] from damien and i was like oh my
god he did sell his stuff
this [ __ ] is crazy now mind you i'm a
grown adult
now and i'm no better but like i really
thought i was like this [ __ ] dmx
is
he's really like you know what i'm
saying like
so that was something he was like really
battling with just kind of like the
battle
which just just for life generally he
found out
like he had a hard life yeah
john says so i mean you know just
follows him growing up as a kid and
stuff like that you know
you know he's really from the streets so
you know it's time to live on the street
and be the homeless and i've been
homeless there's a lot of artists that
actually
came into this game being homeless of
course and having nothing to go to you
know i'm saying so that was some of the
demons you know i'm saying
that that you might be fighting it might
be something like
i'm hungry right now and it's a lady
and and that purse looked real nice and
i'm hungry right now
and i'm contemplating yeah
yeah but you might have to make a hard
decision you know i'm saying so these
are decisions that he
had to deal with so he was just you know
he was just
able to capture it you know i mean you
know and put it